all right i'm laura ingram this is
ingram angle from washington tonight
exposing the senate psych out that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now it looks like as the republicans
scale back the u.s senate race is in
play right now trump's hand-picked
senate candidates might ruin the
republicans chances for retaking the
chamber is it time to actually believe
that the democrats can keep the house
all right right off the bat let me be
very clear tonight
most of what you're hearing about the
republican so-called dire position in
the midterm senate races even the house
sometimes it's designed to do one thing
demoralize the conservative base and
then depress turnout
the every single one of these candidates
let's focus on the senate tonight
deserves to win over their liberal
opponents it's not even close here
now is not the time for second guessing
or see i told you sewing
you all know that i supported dave
mccormick right in in pennsylvania over
mehmed oz
you know i that was clear i did it night
after night but look oz won he's the
nominee
and he's working his tail off he's
traveling the state meeting with every
voter he can trying to win over as many
as possible
john fetterman
he's a younger balder joe biden but in
gym rat clothing
he's a trust funder in a hoodie using
clever consultants and ad men to
campaign for him now he can't actually
argue fetterman kant that the democrat
senate is somehow good for pennsylvania
that's a joke
of course for what they've done on the
fracking issue alone
these people need to be thrown out on
their butts
but the press they want republicans to
believe all hope is lost for these trump
endorsed candidates
and yeah i get it in an ideal world with
a totally objective press corps they'd
all be doing better okay fair
but you fight with the army you have not
the army you wish you had
so here's where our political soldiers
are in some key races this was according
to the website 538 in ohio it's now a
statistical tie between american first
conservative
jd vance and phony populist tim ryan
now in georgia favorite son herschel
walker is less than two points down on
uber liberal rafael warnock
in nevada open borders nightmare
encumbrant uh catherine cortez masto is
up by nearly four on adam laxalt
mark kelly who has been a rubber stamp
for chuck schumer on everything leads
blake masters again he's a young guy
never run before by eight or so
and in the most expensive race in
america in pennsylvania we're supposed
to give up all hope because they say
that uncle fester is beating dr oz by
10.4 points
okay
let me remind everyone it's only the end
of august most people aren't even
following these races yet
but they are following their family
budgets
they know that we're already in
recession says 68
of those polled by nbc
the democrats are so bad for america
that now 58 believe that our best days
are behind us
so if pessimism were a growth stock the
democrats would be long in it
americans are getting poorer and weaker
with liberals running the show
the media knows this the democrats know
this the candidates running on the
fantasy of climate change and abortion
they know it and they don't care
74 of americans are now saying the
country is going in the wrong direction
that is a staggering figure
so i get that the left wants
to cement some narrative in place about
republicans being on the ropes
it is all wishful thinking i'm telling
you this
now there's some other polling out there
that you might want to consider as well
trafalgar is a fairly accurate outfit
they have vance up by five in ohio
laxalt up by three and oz only down four
in pennsylvania
now notice how democrats
well all this is swirling around you
notice how they never ever attack each
other
pelosi even got the squad to quiet down
that was some feat
but leave it to the gop establishment to
shoot inside the tent just in time for
the midterms
a probably a greater likelihood of house
flips
than the senate
senate races are just different they're
statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome
it's mcconnell's way i guess of saying
see i told you so
and just as the media swooned with liz
cheney when she goes rabbit on trump
they swoon over mcconnell when he throws
cold water on the populace
i can't believe i'm saying this but
mitch mcconnell is right mitch mcconnell
is right about candidate quality i agree
with mitch mcconnell can't believe i'm
saying this i agree with him that the
quality of candidate really does matter
much more
now we do not need the senate majority
leader playing the role of a political
pundit we have plenty of those
look it's no secret that mcconnell
prefers old style republicans to the new
populace of the josh hawley ted cruz
variety the new gop is icky to the old
guard and they felt that way long before
trump
remember the rise of the tea party
movement in 2009 that was when i was
back on the radio that worried them a
lot
they were a bunch of xenophobes
conspiracy theorists and isolationists
and then after trump
when he showed up they added cultists to
that list
yet the truth is the real outliers in
the republican party are the bush
republicans
they've been out of step with their own
voters for years
really if you want to be precise about
it
pretty much back to the 2006 midterms we
knew all we had to know back then then
back in 2016 the republican ruling class
they wanted jeb to be president
but no offense the gop base wanted a
fighter to stand up for them they still
want that
yet they get a party leadership that too
often treats them they feel like
second-class citizens
and then when trump wowed everyone when
he became president rattling the old
chamber of commerce hold on the party
the old guard they weren't happy
they tolerated trump but they never
really respected him
and beyond the tone and the style of
trump
they recoiled at his positions on china
trade immigration and the long wars we'd
been fighting
of course in the post-election frenzy
and january 6 all that ma'am those riots
that didn't just give the democrats a
storyline of democracy under attack
it gave the gop establishment an out as
well
senator mcconnell these are the
candidates we have and the left is
descending upon them with vicious ad
campaigns and huge war chests
thankfully mcconnell's super pac is
spending in key races that's good
but think of how much more could be
raised if republicans and even
independents thought it was all for one
one for all and mcconnell
maybe just maybe seems to be getting the
message
here he was today
flipping the senate
what are the chances it's a 50-50
proposition
we've got a 50-50 senate right now
we've got a 50-50 nation
and i think the outcome is likely to be
very very close
either way so
but the stakes will be big
because if both the house and the senate
flip
i think
the president will be a moderate
he won't have any choice
okay
again
we need less of a pundit and more of a
leader
rally the troops we don't need the
number count from mcconnell we need the
troops rallied for america
now it was entirely rational for gop
voters who want to change the senate not
just to empower the old gop
establishment but in these primary races
to choose candidates whom they believe
will actually do the right thing if
they're elected
so instead of complaining about our
candidates or kind of being wishy-washy
on them we should recognize that this
group is actually great
our nominees with a few exceptions like
colorado
are political newcomers they haven't had
a lot of experience but that's okay
they're out there fighting for the
average person they should be respected
for getting in the ring
this is a great makeup to the change of
the senate and we should be excited
about an opportunity to switch things up
in the gop
of course we could have nominated a
bunch of romney clones and then the
press would be happier with us
but that would have been bad for the
country
the whole point of this movement is that
we need a party that looks out for
regular hard-working americans yes
blue-collar americans it doesn't just go
along with whatever the media or the
globalists want we've tried that it
doesn't work
but now is not the time for score
settling certainly not the time for
backbiting i don't want to do it
now is the time to win
to take back the senate stop the biden
wrecking ball from destroying what's
left of america
if our gop leadership really cares about
the future of this country as much as
they say they do
they'll do everything in their power to
elect every single one of these gop
candidates
and that's the angle
and now to tonight's breaking news just
hours ago president trump's legal team
requested the appointment of a special
master to act as a third party in
screening those seized materials from
mar-a-lago for potentially privileged or
even classified information now in their
request the former president's lawyer
lawyers note that law enforcement is a
shield that protects americans it cannot
be used as a weapon
for political purposes
now
my view here is that trump has been most
successful when he's on the offensive so
it was indeed good news to see that the
latest legal response to the raid is
going on the offense hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else